[Musique]
si tu campes est astucieux belle
la plus jeune fille
le plus sérieux
vous avez pas jouer il suffit de vouloir
revenir à un ami
mais bonjour fabrice bonjour tout ça va
bien tiens bon très bien tout bien
élégant affiche justement chic
oui j'ai une grande nouvelle à nous
avons une première aujourd'hui expo
c'est une grande première mais que me
dit tu l'a jamais d'un nouveau jeu quel
jeu le jeu du dse chronologique dans la
grande série trouve l'ordre dans lequel
je suis mais alors mais alors pas là
alors tu vois je te l'expliquer en deux
mots tu te souviens babri tous les
droits quand même recommence à nous deux
oui comment nous deux bah oui on
explique à tout le monde c'est à dire tu
voudrais que je n'explique oui j'ai
compris nous te j'ai parfaitement
compris la 3d ça oui 1 s'est dessinée
s'est dessiné par hervé legrand
oui et alors il ya une histoire mais moi
je vais te les présenter dans un ordre
tout à fait différente dans la descente
voilà alors à moins de reconstituer
l'histoire avec ton intelligence et ta
logique c'est parce que c'est logique
toujours c'est toujours le gie toujours
alors nous sommes avec ce premier dessin
dans un square voilà et nous voyons
c'est ou non c'est pas la peine on lire
dans un square d'arras cua premiers
dessins abadie dont faut aller vite
non mais tu vas voir ah bon on est
toujours dans un square oui mais des
choses ont changé c'est là l'astuce tu
proposes abri effectivement il ya des
choses qui ont changé d'ici là la wii ah
bon oui et troisième et on va leur
passer après encore de la nouveauté au
que des nouveautés oui on va ça vient
comme ça on va pas non plus se gérer
est-ce que je peux pas me concentrer
mois pour moi j'ai trouvé
elle retourne repas 50 genre commence tu
veux attention je repasse un autre
dessin et je repasse un troisième dessin
où j'ai trouvé parce qu'alors il ya un
détail qui me saute aux yeux la situe
vers mais nous allons maintenant
remettre les dessins dans l'ordre wen
soyons logiques au début de l'histoire
enfin j'imagine qu'au début le banc
évident
six personnes sur le banc non alors
ensuite j'ai vu qu'il y avait un
personnage assis sur ce banc as
bon mais attention troisième et dernier
dessin ce personnage s'est assis sur un
banc dont manifestement la peinture
nette est passée chine a laissé des
traces sur le banc et il a des traces de
peinture dans le dos de sa veste
ça me paraît être l'ordre logique des
choses c'est ça a très bien tu as trouvé
ben j'en suis j'en suis fort aise
oui bah moi je suis très fier et bientôt
tu sors tu veux bien parce que je vais
dire trouver belle belle énigme ou suède
accord le pour le jus du point commun
vous avez déjà dit vous avez vu les
dessins effet ce n'est pas facile quand
même c'est un super bien on est prêts on
peut l'appeler
ah oui bien sûr fabrice oui mais voilà
mon voilà me voilà fabrice on fait le
jeu du point commun tu le connais mais
explique le dos un petit peu encore une
fois chez vous je vous rappeler
brièvement ce qu'est le jeu du point
commun c'est extrêmement simple belle
belle tout cas encore et pousse moussu
vont représenter quelque chose
mais et c'est quelque chose ont un point
commun et c'est à nous de découvrir ce
qu'est ce point commun bien entendu vous
jouez avec moi nous allons essayer de le
deviner tous ensemble nous vous écoutons
messeigneurs bon alors voilà aujourd'hui
moi je suis un fleuve
oui mais un fleuve paresseux tu vois pas
du tout du genre torrent ni tumulte non
moi je coule semble pressé comme ça tu
veux comme comme la loire où la scène je
fais des tours des détours que si je
n'ai pas du tout envie de lyme jeter
dans la mer ce qui est très agréable
c'est de se promener sur bois en bateau
est très agréable et pas dangereux
et toi belles belles que bien
moi je suis une chevelure féminine mort
et une blonde rousse enfin comme tu veux
une chevelure bien celui qu'on peut
trouver aussi bien autour d'un visage
d'enfant couteau de celui d'une jeune
mariée d'une mère de famille d'une grand
mère etc si je lis que lorsqu'on l'a
possède on n'a plus envie de mettre un
chapeau décès alors alors pour l'instant
je nage je dois le dire à toi
bon bah moi moi moi c'est pas aussi
jolie que bell bell ce que je vais
présenter son nom je suis une grosse
ceinture non un ceinturon même c'est
comment comment non les militaires la
solide taillée dans un client bien mais
perd un gros match je peux aussi être
une une élégante ceinture de femmes
enfin je ne veux pas faire de
concurrence à bell bell est franchement
avec la lure que j'ai il vaut mieux que
je me contente de mon vieux ceinturon
voilà oui dit don mais dit dans l'élite
danser pour commode ça alors toi tout
con quand tu es un fleuve toi bell bell
tu es une chevelure et toi pouces moussu
un ceinturon ces gènes trouvés mais
c'était juste parce que c'est facile
ratée et tu te dis que tu étais un
fleuve blanc tu m'as parlé de la scène
c'est ce qui me fait retrouver une
boucle de la seine le dire que de la
faire une boue dans les cheveux et une
boucle bien entendu en saturant c'était
juste un je t'assure que j'ai vraiment
failli
l'europe est soi disant qu'on fabrique
bravo moi je me vis tu me rejoins tout à
l'heure pour le jeudi 9
oui entendu a tout de suite alerté trop
versé c'est à nous de belbèze c'est à
toi chérie schetagne de la vraie coupe
devient ainsi un appareil visé ton
orthographe
ça va barder emmène au million d'années
ça va arrive ça va aller bon alors cette
fois ci c'est qu'à tenter crayon match
aidé au tableau travaux alors du mois
c'est un mot en cette lettre cette
bourse montre commence par alors qu'ils
commencent par un m
comme maman mais oui mais voilà alors
cinq petits trains oui comme d'habitude
1 3 5 et alors la dernière 1 c j'aime
pense ça tienne pas sa voix non parce
que là ça ne voit pas grand chose c'est
un pas important s'est instruit au nom
donc c'est pas un fruit non alors c'est
une plante non plus ce n'est pas une
plante un animal ah oui oui c'est un
animal tu as trouvé ce qu'il choisit
toujours ce gentil forêts à besse aime
bien sa source d'inspiration la forêt
alors c'est un arbre un animal c'est un
animal excuse bruit c'est un animal
c'est un grosse un gros animaux non il
est petit tout petit tout petit petit
petit c'est un rongeur
oh non non c'est pas cette affaire c'est
un animal qui est qui courent non pas
les grands noms ils rendent pas sol oui
ils volent à l'horizon non non c'est pas
un oiseau hamas n 8 ana c'est grinçant
est ce que tu veux je te donne encore
une lettre la grille m oui elle est un
alors la quatrième c1 s
un petit animal qui vole il est rapide
bout pepy
tu permets tu m'as dit combien de
lettres passait pour fin août moi je
pensais tu m'as dit buzz disent oui il
existe une penserait pas par hasard un
moustique s'y trouvaient et ennuierait
de dire à nos amis comment tu écris
moustiques
comment j'ai créé boujettaoui bain avant
que je me fais ça tu vas pas de fâcher
comment tu écris moustiques ba.n aux us
tu es ici moose creek voit un petit
petit craquement et les mauves sti ces
moustiques un bâton âge mais c'est comme
ça que tu écris mousty bas mais je vois
là comme on écrit moustiques
comment voilà tout le monde le sait
singes sauve-toi naturellement m usd t
il
oui et après bac
où en tant que ça voilà comment les
crimes où c'était compliqué ça je me
demande si un jour il va écrire
correctement
non je suis à mon programme je fais pas
de progrès en obtiendrait c'est vrai dit
dites à risque ou de moustiques un pays
il ya peut-être quelque chose que je
peux vous apprendre quoi d'abord ce que
vous ne savez pas ce qu'on ne dit pas on
a été piqué par un moustique mais une
moustiques
c'est là que les femelles qui piquent
pas les mâles et puis ce qui est le plus
important ça c'est un petit truc que je
vous donne pour les démangeaisons et
bien il faut se frotter avec du jus de
persil c'est très efficace
1 oui saviez pas non plus hein pourquoi
mode d'avoir du jus
ainsi si vous allez à la campagne vous
promener avec votre petit bouquet de
persil voilà c'est tout enfin c'est bien
c'est bien tu ne rattrape toujours en
nous donnant des renseignements
intéressants et heureusement car bon
donc encore oui si un débat d'une vers
moi je me demande si je ne devrais pas
allé du côté de bell bell voir ça nous a
préparé son jeu musique tu fais ce que
tu veux tu t'es désintéressent de la
question
non pas du tout je fais ce que tu veux
je te laisse entièrement libre je le
demande s'il n'est pas un peu jeune loup
aux nombreux moins drôle de tête
la table c'est ce que j'ai fait si la
musique tibesar et toi qu'en 2007 les
soldats d'origine
[Musique]
winnezeele on continue à jouer avec
toutes ces notes tu sais comment oui
avec toutes les notes de la gamme i do
ré mi fa sol la si do they say fenêtre
que vous avez apprise je pense depuis le
temps et tu va me proposer sans doute
des phrases qui nous éblouit des débuts
de meaux où il a dit oui et moi je dois
avec les notes sur la portée musicale
complète est ce que tu vas dire
exactement alors aujourd'hui je voudrais
que tu m'aides à installer mon
appartement est pour l'instant il n'y a
rien dans cet appartement pas un meuble
pas un tapis je vis comme une sauvage
dans une véritable véritable oui une
véritable la halle et il faut qu'il
cherche je cherche c'est pas facile
c'est pour une véritable nous me
véritable fable adresse sol si dos mais
ça va pas y arriver aucune d'elles est
aux pubs de lennon est un petit peu plus
difficile parce que j'ai passé une note
qui a des noms différents à une autre
cadre de nos différents vite c'est la
première note c'est le dos le lot
s'appelle aussi utile dans une véritable
lutte cissé ben voilà dos et désigna
même note c'est vrai alors donc j'évite
dans une véritable but mais je tiens à
ce que cet endroit où j'ai lu boum boum
si mon bon monsieur
oui à l'accord de cm2 ne bouge et élus -
blouse bleue cl oui il vivait vais me
prête à donner tout de suite ma tu vas
voir 2 me s'il a au mieux c'est parfait
alors cet endroit où j'ai élu domicile
et je veux qu'il soit très élégant très
raffiné surtout très confortable avant
tout il faudra que tu m'aides à y
accrocher des reee
c'est facile ça déry des rideaux d'eau
et je voudrais que ce soit des rideaux
13 ip très long qui tombe jusqu'aux des
rideaux qui tombe jusqu'aux jusqu'au
jusqu'au haut voilà jusqu'au sol c'est
ça et elle ce propos je te signale que
je ne mettrai pas de tapis par terre non
je reconnais que c'est plus chaud plus
confortable mais quand on reçoit des
amis on risque toujours qu'ils y
laissent tomber leurs cendres de gare
ah oui oui car oui oui de 6,6 à l'égard
de garde
on pourrait dire aussi de leurs gardes
oui bien entendu ça sera la même
oui c'est ça mais tu si c'est pas
agréable du tout les cendres aussi par
terre pour que ce soit pratique ce
serait du parquet mais je voudrais que
ce parc est soit très brillant un miroir
et je compte sur toi pour l'encaustiqué
je te rassure tout de suite ce sera à
moi
là
l'aller comment eh ben il faut que tu
remplaces l'etrat les la llr par des
notes un drame à la wii et six notes
dépêche-toi abassi note est passée note
1 dépêche toi parce que c'est difficile
et je voudrais temps à peindre un sol
oui c'est ça le marquer sa seule femme
vit à 6 oui un safari
la heavy c oui parce que c'est un
parquet tu m'as dit insolent fassi là
c'est vrai que si ces montres halal
halal rc2 sols faciles à cirer
fabrice tu très bien je t'engage tir
poteau récompense situera droit à un
repos bien méritée et je t'autorise
entassent ayant jamais de mes photos il
profs sont munis de confortables si oui
alors ce dossier et c'est parfait alors
on chante we abano as l'on termine en
musique bien entendu
est-ce que vous êtes prêts musique s'il
vous plaît
[Musique]
les tapis
déjà papa et d'amis d'état il se plaint
que la vie moi je résiste et rzeszow
fait des choses mais comme je n'ai pas
de baignoire l'hérault
sont les quatre amis sont ratés sont
réunis mais y'a qu'ça me sens heureux
d'arriver à blâmer
oui
[Musique]
mais non
david a joué aujourd'hui et je vis à vis
[Musique]
de vouloir devenir amis
e
et puis
[Musique]
m
e
[Musique]
etc